I think to tell you the truth I think
he's worn out from doing 10,000 things
every day even when we tell him to take
rests he doesn't take them so I think
that plays a major role um but also the
way our lives have changed has been
overwhelming so when he says he's
overwhelmed all the time I think that
that's accurate yeah I mean Jordan was
saying to me that it's overwhelmed by
the sense of responsibility he feels and
the influence that he has now over so
many people
brings with it the burden of that
responsibility and it's something he
feels very acutely do you see that with
your dad on a daily basis oh oh
definitely if people approach him on the
street he gets emotional quite
frequently um because the conversations
are emotional so people come up and say
this is how hard my life was and maybe
my life is still hard but I'm managing
to take it on in a more positive way and
I'm I credit you for that